bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat le 19 juin la
mission de contrôle et d'évaluation de
la sécurité sociale a organisé une table
ronde sur la thématique des médicaments
génériques un médicament générique
c'est un médicament similaire à un autre
médicament rappelé médicaments princeps
qui est lui autorisé et produit par une
marque il ne peut être en effet
commercialisé qu'après l'expiration du
brevet du médicament princeps
généralement à un moindre coût
et c'est d'ailleurs là tout son intérêt
ainsi par exemple en 2012 plus de 2,4
milliards d'euros ont été ainsi
économisés grâce au recours à ces
médicaments génériques en france
mais tout n'est pas si rose selon un
rapport de l'igas l'inspection générale
des affaires sociales
la matière première à partir de laquelle
est fabriqué ces médicaments génériques
est le plus souvent produit à l'étranger
notamment hors de l'union européenne
ça pose la question de contrôle de la
qualité de ses médicaments une qualité
jugé insuffisant par ce même rapport de
l'igas alors comment renforcer le
contrôle qualité à l'intérieur des
frontières de l'union européenne
des réponses maintenant sur public sénat
très bonne matinée à tous sur notre
chaîne la présidente
chers collègues mesdames messieurs donc
l'amex a décidé mois de décembre dernier
de s'intéresser à la question des
médicaments génériques qui suscite le
sujet régulièrement des interrogations
c'est dans cet objectif que nous
organisons cet après-midi deux tables
rondes la première démarre sur le thème
princeps générique qu'elle équivalence
tous ses aspects scientifiques et la
seconde portera sur l'évaluation de la
politique française du médicament
générique pour cette première table
ronde nous recevons le professeur
dominique maraninchi
en face de moi directeur général de
l'agencé nationale de sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé qui
était accompagné de monsieur philippe
bel à sa droite directeur donc à lagence
le professeur à la stib re de l'académie
de pharmacie et les professeurs jean
paul tin man et genre ça ça membre de
l'académie nationale de médecine
l'académie de médecine a adopté le 14
février 2012 un rapport sur la place des
génériques dans la prescription qui
avait eu un écho médiatique certain
avenir comme ça l'académie de pharmacie
a adopté le 5 décembre 2012 un rapport
sur les médicaments génériques pour
romandie après avoir publié divers
autres documents scientifiques sur ce
sujet au delà de l'actualité récente qui
restent assez mystérieuses et qui aurait
pu concerner tous types de médicaments
nous savons bien que un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes se manifeste régulièrement
notre pays à l'égard des génériques
notamment en ce qui concerne
l'équivalence de leur efficacité avec le
médicament princeps
c'est donc sur ce thème là très
précisément que porte la première
table-ronde je vous remercie monsieur le
sort messieurs d'avoir accepté de
participer à nos travaux
je vous propose dans un premier temps la
parole à monsieur marc anaky donc pour
une dizaine de minutes un peu plus si
vous le souhaitez en président en
précisant à toutes et tous que ces
tables rondes on sait s'ils sont
ouvertes à la presse
et font l'objet d'une captation vidéo
pour diffusion sur le site internet donc
tenez vous bien pendant l'après midi
ce professeur vous avez la parole il sut
président mesdames et messieurs à mettre
duction je voudrais compléter votre
propos sur les documents dont nous
disposons et qui sont à la disposition
de des personnes qui ont à réfléchir et
décider un document qui a engagé la
responsabilité de l'agent sur un rapport
sur les génériques qui était publié en
fin d'année dernière
utiliser le point sur la situation des
génériques en france et dans le monde
d'une façon très large et qui reprenait
un certain nombre d'éléments mais il
était pourtant pour nous important de
transmettre des documents sources plutôt
que d'avoir des informations un peu
éparses et qui fasse la synthèse
donc c'est un assez gros documents que
je recommande à l'auditoire
c'est quoi les génériques pour pour l'
agence je vais pas revenir sur la
définition mais quand même il faut se
rappeler qu'il s'agit de médicaments
le médicament dont la qualité et la
sécurité est le principe actif sont
identiques par rapport au princeps ils
ont la même forme pharmacologiques
ils ont la même biodisponibilité donc la
même bioéquivalence donc ça peut
paraître un peu techno mai
pour nous qu est-ce qui fait un
médicament c'est la substance active
qu'il contient et qu'est-ce qui fait
l'efficacité d'un médicament
c'est sa distribution à l'intérieur de
l'organisme et sa capacité d'être
absorbée et distribué donc sur ces
critères là pour nous les génériques
sont des médicaments comme les autres et
quand nous les traitons nous les
traitons
comme les autres qu'ils soient
génériques ou princeps mais je veux
revenir sur quelques points
il ya beaucoup médicaments qui sont
autorisés en france comme vous le savez
on est de l'ordre de 5000 de 3,5 milles
substance et il ya mille principes
actifs qui sont génériques inscrit au
répertoire dont 7000 spécialité donc ce
sont des médicaments très représentés
comme pour tous les autres médicaments
il passe par un processus d'évaluation
avant leur commercialisation qui
s'appelle l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché qui est le plus souvent nationale
sur notre responsabilité et c'est un des
domaines majeurs d'activité de lagence
en termes d'autorisations de mise sur le
marché c'est essentiellement pour les
produits génériques dans 80% des cas les
autorisations de mise sur le marché des
génériques sont sont donnés dans le
cadre d'une procédure nationale
plus rarement ça ça dépend des chiens il
ya des génériques qui sont enregistrés
au niveau européen et qui ensuite feront
l'objet d'une commercialisation
quels sont les critères de
l'enregistrement des autorisations de
mise sur le marché qui fondent
notre décision d'autoriser ou
d'interdire un de ses produits et en
quoi ça peut créer des ambiguïtés dans
la compréhension sur les génériques par
rapport aux produits princeps
il ya des éléments dans le dossier qui
n'existe pas je dirais par nature je me
permets de faim définition négative
il n'y a pas d'étude clinique qui est
fourni à l'appui du dossier démontrant
la relation bénéfice risque du principe
actif dans le traitement d'une maladie
spécifié dans son indication
d'ailleurs ça serait besogneux et
stupide de le faire puisque qu'est-ce
qui fait l'efficacité d'un principe
actif c'est le principe actif la
condition que le principe actif à
distribuer dans l'organisme
donc le fondement du dossier
d'enregistrement est sûr de la qualité
pharmaceutique et sur un dossier de
bioéquivalence il ya d'autres éléments
messieurs donc parmi les grands de
tension ou incertitudes
beaucoup de médecins disent oui mais ça
pas été on n'a pas testé ce qui marche
ce qui est efficace dans un médicament
c'est son principe actif si on retrouve
son principe actif de façon strictement
identique à celui du princeps des effets
thérapeutiques doivent être strictement
les mêmes et c'est vrai évidemment à
l'intérieur même de d'une chaîne de
princeps qui fabrique plusieurs fois du
principe actif chaque fois qu'ils
fabriquent du principe actif ce principe
actif est remis d'enjeux médicaments et
a toujours les mêmes c'est fait donc
l'agencé très active dans ce domaine en
france où savait que les génériques sont
une fois enregistré autorisé rentrer
dans un répertoire qui est une
spécialité française mais qu'un impact
pratique assez important en terme de
transparence des chats et 100 % des
produits autorisés en france rentre au
répertoire depuis 2004 donc c'est
relativement siens et ce qui permet à
tous
les acteurs de la prescription de la
distribution de pouvoir faire ce qu'on
appelle une substitution puisque le
répertoire garantie qu'ils peuvent
substituer de façon équivalente ce type
de produits je parle essentiellement des
eneric par voie orale
je vais mettre une petite note sur le
générique de produits injectables qui
sont beaucoup plus rares mais autant
anticiper sur les questions auparavant
eux ne font pas l'objet d'études de
bioéquivalence puisqu'on very simplement
que c'est le même produit à la même dose
dans la même poule et que lorsqu'elles
étaient injectés dans l'organisme de il
doit donner deux les mêmes effets
puisque c'est strictement le même
produit il ya eu des contestations sur
ce sujet en disant oui mais on n'a pas
confiance on a l'impression que excusez
moi de parler de rumeurs mais ça peut
arriver jusqu à vous aussi
on a l'impression que tu es
l'antibiotique la vancomycine
colombienne il ya une étude en colombie
qui montrent qu'elle est moins efficace
que la vancomycine d'origine dont nous
avons nous avons contesté cette approche
puisqu'il s'agit nous chaque fois qu'on
autorise un médicament en france
on vérifie complètement sa qualité
pharmaceutique et s'il n'était pas le
cas de saint clément comme ici
colombienne d'autre part pour rassurer
aussi pour se faire une idée personnelle
nous avons aussi des laboratoires de
contrôle et sur les injectables et
notamment la peur comme ici nous avons
fait une étude chez invivo pas chez
l'homme mais chez l'animal étudier
toutes les femmes devant comme is in
génériques et nous avons trouvé qu'il
n'y avait pas de différence par rapport
aux principes d'origine qui a disparu
mais dont on a pu retrouver deux
le principe actif donc il était
important d'avoir le maximum de données
de transparence sur les médicaments
génériques pour que les usagers les
prescripteurs comprennent que ce ne sont
pas des médicaments au rabais le
deuxième enjeu qui va être le sait pas
parce que c'est moins cher que c'est de
piètre qualité
c'est moins cher peut-être parce que les
les princeps sont trop chers et en tout
cas c'est le légitime qui soit moins
cher puisqu'il ya moins d'études
cliniques qui sont faites pour
enregistrer un produit générique que
temps ce n'est pas le cas nous avons une
politique active lagence autorise
interdit en se servant d'un système
d'évaluation mais aussi de capacités
d'inspection et de contrôle
donc nous avons diligenté autant donner
toutes les réticences qui assure les
génériques est pas parce que nous avions
une crainte particulière de nombreuses
politiques de contrôle est par exemple
pour un générique du plô pedro gueule
qui est produit que vous connaissez nous
avons testé dans nos laboratoires la
totalité des génériques comprimé par
comprimé et la quantité principe actif
et la caisse du principe est actif est
strictement la même nous en déclenchant
des des campagnes d'inspection
car vous aurez posé les questions
j'imagine sur ce sujet on peut se
demander aussi ces médicaments sont
moins chères parce qu'ils sont moins
biens fabriqués ou éventuellement dans
les pays où les contrôles seraient moins
importants le résultat d'inspection sont
coordonnées
évidemment avec
l' agence européenne sans coordonnées
avec la food and drug administration' et
il ya souvent des ambiguïtés au tour ces
inspections
vous verrez dans les rapports
d'inspection que nous rendons publics et
notamment dans la branche générique que
nos inspections découvre parfois des
anomalies graves et parfois des
anomalies mineures
tout simplement parce que ce sont des
inspections ciblées c'est à dire que
lorsqu'on a un doute on va inspecter
pour sanctionner est fermé donc c'est
dans une politique de surveillance
par contre les inspections de routine
qui sont faites sur les sites de
génériques comme sur les sites de
princesse ne montre même pas ne vend pas
différent ce dernier point puisque nous
sommes en france nous avons une
politique d'inspection de contrôle et de
surveillance qui est identique pour les
génériques et pour les princeps et très
fréquemment
ce sont les mêmes sierne les mêmes
usines les mêmes procédés de fabrication
qui sont appliquées dans la chaîne
génériques comme dans comme dans la
chaîne princeps
c'est pas un sujet simple et c'est un
sujet qui est surveillé il nous semble
c'est pour ça que une politique de
transparence et d'information et le
traitement au cas par cas est nécessaire
afin de rassurer sur la qualité et la
sécurité des médicaments que prennent
les patients français dernier point
comme tout médicament qui contient un
principe actif il ya des bénéfices et
les risques et donc nous avons une
politique de vigilance sur tous les
produits
et quelle que soit la marque et nous
avons été amené à faire plusieurs
retrait du marché de produits mais nous
traitons équitablement bien évidemment
les génériques comme les princeps
quand un produit est dangereux idée il
est médicalement actifs
nous n'avons pas de repérages
particuliers malgré quelques recherches
spécifiques d'événements de vigilance
qui serait ce plus fréquents chez les
avait des produits génériques qui
avaient des produits princeps
mais c'est notre attitude générale qui
fait que nous nous traitons l'ensemble
des principes actifs en situation de
vigilance
et on va pas laisser sur le marché un
produit un principe actif dangereux ni
un générique dangereux donc on travaille
globalement sur la sécurité des patients
sur l'ensemble des classes donc et le
dernier point que vous connaissez c'est
est-ce que c'est efficace est ce que
nous avons une politique générique
efficace en ce qui concerne la nsm pour
nos efficacités signifie transparence et
réactivité
donc c'est pas parce qu'on a inscrit un
point d'abord c'est pas parce qu'on a
autorisé un produit qui soit génériques
ou non qu'il faut l'utiliser donc l'abus
du médicament fait toujours du mal
d'autre part un produit un médicament se
situer dans des indications
particulières et je voudrais insister
sur le fait des situations médicalement
sensible
qui peuvent induire des tensions
lorsqu'il ya une substitution un peu
forcé par rapport à un usage qu'on fait
des personnes brossé ma culture médicale
mais vous le savez notamment chez les
personnes âgées qui sont habitués à
prendre une présentation le changement
de présentation peut arriver à les
déstabiliser et la faire perdre
confiance maintenant de ta des
dispositions réglementaires permettent à
ce que la ressemblance du produit se
rapproche le plus le plus possible du
princeps
mais c'est un problème non négligeable
et comme vous le savez c'est aussi pour
des situations à risque comme les
transplanter des situations à risque
comme les épilepsies chroniques de
l'enfant
on peut citer aussi bien sur la
substitution des hormones thyroïdiennes
où la problématique de la substitution
chez les personnes qui sont pour une
maladie chronique qui ont été
péniblement équilibré par une approche
thérapeutique est parfois mal vécue et
mal comprise et souhaits source de
doutes
et dans ces cas-là de doute qui a
entraîné des incidents médicaux dont
nous sommes particulièrement attentifs à
ces produits dans ces situations
sensibles puisque la bonne cohésion
entre le prescripteur
le distributeur est la personne qui
reçoit le produit est un gage aussi de
sécurité d'acceptabilité voilà mais ce
sont des situations
heureusement rares j'espère ne pas avoir
été trop merci de cette présentation on
donne la parole donc alors je ne sais
pas dans quel ordre
se rassied ou si vous voulez monsieur le
président merci de m'avoir conviés à
cette table ronde nous représente
l'académie nationale de pharmacie qui
effectivement comme vous l'avez souligné
a fait un rapport copieux fin 2012 dont
vous je pense vous avez la disposition
sinon je vous donnerai n'y a pas de
problème il est téléchargeable sur le
fil academy et donc notre souci a été
comme toujours pour laquelle et
pharmacie de d'avoir un apport à un
abord purement scientifiques
c'est-à-dire il ya des choses qui sont
dites
on va regarder si c'est scientifiquement
prouvé qu'elles sont les éléments dont
dans la littérature scientifique qui
permet de montrer quelque chose ou qui
s'opposent à quelque chose donc en ce
qui concerne les génériques
effectivement nous avons fait une
analyse qu'on appelle bibliographiques
et méta analyse dire qu'on a fait une
étude systématique de tout ce qui était
pratiquement publier leurs petits
paquets totalement exhaustif parce que
c'est ces tâches impossibles mais tout
ce qui était accessible permettant de
régler cette question de voir si
effectivement le fait qu' une bio
équivalence
comme l'a expliqué vincent mareine à qui
ses terres le fait que un médicament
absorber
arriva la même convient tant c'est avec
la même quantité dans l'organisme
impliquait qu'il y est une équivalence
clinique parce que c'est sale argument
qui est souvent opposé il ya deux
arguments qui sont de dire un
les études de bioéquivalence ne sont pas
fiables c'est le premier élément donc et
deuxièmement même si les produits sont
bien eux qui va lancer l'exemple des
antibiotiques injectables et par
définition c'est forcément parce qu'on
injecte dans le sens ya aucun problème
au niveau de l'absorption par définition
est donc à oui mais même si c'est dieu
qui va l'en il ya des différences
clinique
alors pour les deux parties de la
discussion nous avons effectivement fait
cette étude du beau graphique montrant
qu' aucune étude de méta analyse aucune
étude publiés dans des journaux
scientifiques études je dirais dont on
peut s'assurer de la pertinence et les
critères des vaisseaux d'une étude
scientifique c'est pas parce que quelque
chose ait publié fait style dans un
journal je dirais important c'est pas un
gars en totale de qualité donc et les
critères qui permettent de savoir si une
étude clinique par exemple et qualité
double aveugle pas double aveugle qui
est le sponsor de l'étude
combien de sujets étant impliqué est ce
qu'elle est un multi centric ou pas etc
et en se basant sur ces critères déjà ça
permet d'éliminer un certain nombre
d'études qui sont des études qui sont
biaisés par nature c'est à dire que par
exemple il n'ya pas double aveugle on ne
sait pas exactement quel médicament a
été utilisé comme comparateur s'est pas
dit dans l'article donc bien entendu
c'est plus les pas possible de savoir
exactement et de juger de la pertinence
et lorsqu'on prend toutes les études une
fois qu'elles ont été classées par les
critères de qualité ou s'aperçoit que
pour la totalité des classes
thérapeutiques que nous avons évalué
même les médicaments anti les
antiépileptiques immuno suppresseurs
antibiotiques etc pour lequel il ya un
salon de discussion
il n'y a aucune différence significative
entre les génériques et les princeps
alors
souligne d'ailleurs que pour sa mana qui
ne l'a pas indiqué je ne pense pas que
très souvent les laboratoires de
princeps ont leur propre générique
heures c'est à dire que ils vous vendent
à la fois le princess moi je suis
pharmacien hospitalier
donc je connais le discours de beaucoup
de visiteurs médicaux qui sait que c'est
c'est le basque ont changé près de masse
du laboratoire prince est ils vous
disent le plus grand mal des génériques
et après avec le mas du laboratoire
générique de lui-même
la même société je n'en citerai pas me
vous reconnaissez vous disent que leurs
génériques est parfait donc voyez sorte
de schizophrénie entretenu et donc c'est
un élément qui montre coeur à mon avis
genre ça vaut ce que ça vaut mais enfin
qui montre que dans ce domaine de la
méfiance vis à vis des génériques qui a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'intérêt il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de lobby qui
agissent en sous-main en sachant et tout
le monde la halle le 5e nous sommes une
singularité française ont fait cette
exception culturelle j'y suis très
sensible à titre personnel enfin dans ce
domaine
dans ce domaine c'est un peu étrange de
s'apercevoir qu'on s'aperçoit qu'on
utilise quasiment trois fois moins de
génériques aux états unis pour les etats
unis c'est pas comme nous c'est ce qu'on
veut d'accord mais si vous prenez
l'allemagne
prenez l'angleterre et d'autres pays on
voit couronné aux 63 ou 64 % je crois en
allemagne alors que nous sommes à 25
pour son utilisation des génériques dont
il ya quand même une singularité
française qui ensemble d'explications
mais qui de toute façon ne sont pas
basés sur un rationnel scientifique
alors je n'ai pas à juger les autres
rationnelle qui sont sous jacent mais
d'un point de vue scientifique il n'y a
pas de différence alors par contre et là
je suis d'accord avec le pousseur marana
kidder les études le montrent les études
montrent que quand par exemple 1
un médicament n'est pas administré en
aveugle ou un essai clinique
j'ai un exemple tout à fait typique à
vous citer ces petites histoires de
chasse mais une étude a été faite avec
un médicament dans l'écolo pâtit
fonctionnel tout ça c'est des maladies
notamment de la femme pour lesquels les
paramètres psychologiques sont
relativement importants et bien le même
médicament même médicament je pensais
virginia princesse le même médicament a
été administré donc à trois groupes le
premier groupe était un groupe dans
lequel le médecin prescrive et le
produit avec empathie c'est à dire
qu'ils disaient voilà je vous prescris
ce médecin ce médicament pardon ma femme
à la même pathologique vous je lui donne
avait confiance et c'est le deuxième
groupe le médecin donne est bien sûr le
même médicament mais de façon tout à
fait neutre visage de glace voilà une
produit ce médicament qui est un
troisième groupe
le médecin disait vous savez c'est mon
pharmacien qui m'oblige à utiliser les
génériques
moi j'y crois pas trop etc je vous le
donne mes bons résultats
soixante pour son efficacité dans le
premier coup 40 20 donc on va d'un
facteur trois lits et simplement au fait
que dans un cas le médecin a une vision
positive et dans le deuxième cas le
médecin une vision négative
donc voyez que pour un simple de
pathologies pas pour toutes ce type
d'argument est extrêmement important
donc effectivement effectivement pour
des médicaments destinés à des
pathologies pour lequel les les aspects
psychologiques sont importants
l'épilepsie en étant tenu d'une part
dont les maladies du système nerveux
central les dépressions etc
on sait très bien que les aspects
psychologiques sont extrêmement
importantes dans la survenue de signes
cliniques objectif j'entends assez pas
bon et bien on s'aperçoit que dans ces
pathologies là effectivement si le
médecin prescripteur dit oulala je vous
le donne mais c'est vraiment parce qu'on
m'oblige à vous le donner
il est certain qu y aura un événement
indésirable pourquoi parce que dans
l'efficacité total de médicaments
il ya deux éléments il yal éléments
objectifs pharmacologiquement lié au
fait que un médicament est absorbée âge
sur des récepteurs et c'est un expert et
puis il ya une composante psychologique
tout le monde le sait bien puisqu'on
sait bien que l'effet placebo une sebo
existe même des patients cancéreux au
dernier degré on leur donne de du
chlorure de sodium injectables la place
de morphine 20% sont soulagés alors
qu'on bourre donc ça veut bien dire que
les requêtes cynologique ennuyante
placebo ou nocebo dans le sens inverse
c'est à dire ah oui ça va pas me réussir
donc ça va pas me réussit et donc c'est
un élément extrêmement important alors
la somme totale
l'activité d'un médicament c'est vrai
c'est à la fois la somme l'activité
objectif il a tué ce que j'appelle les
facteurs extrinsèques notamment la
confiance du patient la façon dans
l'environnement présentent les choses et
un certain nombre d'éléments
psychologique donc je pense
qu'effectivement c'est sur cet aspect là
qu'il faut travailler dans le cas de la
substitution par génériques et
d'ailleurs on voit très bien que si on
fait passer un prince f pour un
générique et vi et vice et versa eh bien
on a exactement avec le princeps la même
problématique avec le générique donc ça
a été largement publiés les psychologues
connaissent très bien cette ce principe
1 il ya même une étude récente qu'il
allait publier sur les coca cola vous
savez on a fait boire différents le même
coca cola 1 en disant ça c'est du
pepsi-cola du coca cola épisode fera et
bien tout le monde a trouvé quelqu'un ce
qui était marqué coca light peak qui
était meilleur que les auteurs s'étaient
même produit donc ça prouve bien que ce
critère est générale et je dirais
spécifique à l'espèce humaine
donc pour nous résumer en termes
scientifiques aucun élément ne permet de
dire actuellement que objectif que un
générique soit différent d'un princeps
en termes d'efficacité à condition il
rejoint le professeur marc un acquis que
le traitement soit utilisé de la même
façon parce que bien entendu qu'est ce
qui se passe si le patient n'a pas
confiance parce qu'on lui dicte la
tension etc
qu'est-ce qui se passe il prend pas son
médicament vous savez que le problème de
la compliance et un problème majeur dans
les maladies chroniques la moitié des
patients hypertendus ne prête pas leur
traitement
et c'est pratiquement la même chose
maintenant certains anti cancéreux par
voie orale
je connais pas l'accord l'adisq et
monsieur mais je pense que il ya pas mal
de problème là-dessus également c'est
donc c'est la chronicité fait que le
patient qui n'est pas comme on voudrait
qu'il soit ne prend pas son médicament
parce que il oublie parce que ça lui
fait mal au ventre parce que si etc
on est tous comme ça et donc
effectivement si en plus on rajoute à
cette non-adhérents spontanée de tout
patient quel qu'il soit je dirais une
pression en lui disant oui ou laissant
sous-entendre que le produit qu'on va
lui prescrire ou qu'on va lui dispenser
risque de pas être aussi efficaces que
le poids le produit initial
bien entendu vous avez beaucoup de
chance pour que chez certains patients
particulièrement réceptifs à cette à cet
avis et bien effectivement il se passe
quelque chose d'épique tizi vais je pas
prendre le produit puisque c'est pas
celui que mon médecin m'a prescrit
d'habitude
donc voilà ce que je puis dire donc
aucun élément objectif scientifique
permettant de montrer qui est une
différence en termes pharmacologique un
d'efficacité entre princeps et
génériques
par contre effectivement il peut y avoir
des différences mais lié au fait
essentiellement que du manque de
confiance plus ou moins entretenu
vis-à-vis des génériques et donc qu'il
faut à mon avis lutter contre 7,7
propagande je dirais négative vis-à-vis
des génériques alors se tient à
souligner monsieur présent qu'il est
strictement aucun conflit d'intérêts
j'oublie de le dire il avis les
laboratoires génériques
merci merci monsieur le professeur donc
après l'académie nationale de pharmacie
l'académie nationale de médecine à
messieurs les professeurs se passe
comment merci monsieur sont liés comme
la présidente madame messieurs bon
goûter
je prends la parole en dernier mais je
pense que le rapport de l'académie de
médecine a été le premier de publier
avec le retentissement que vous avez
ok lorsque je voudrais c'est vous
préciser d'abord très clairement la
position de l'académie de médecine
on a pris acte de l'utilisation des
génériques sans aucune ambiguïté sachant
qu'il s'agit d'une décision mondiale
généralisée et notre propos de la
question que nous nous posons est la
seule les génériques poser doivent être
parfaites proposés doivent être
parfaitement adapté à la substitution et
il faut que le remplacement de l'un par
l'autre se fasse sans problèmes
alors pourquoi avons-nous réagi et bien
c'est une auto saisine de l'académie
nous avons réagi à différents appels de
praticiens eux comme vous le savez
l'académie de médecine est surtout
constitué de dospital aux universitaires
médecins et ses praticiens qui sont soit
nos anciens étudiants soit nous
corresponde à nos élèves on signerait
des substitutions avec d'apparent draria
sur l'activité des différences de
présentation
quelquefois des difficultés
d'acceptabilité ce jeu vous reviendrez
sur ce point et parfois même
d'identification c'est à dire le nom du
produit
je le travaille de l'académie n'a pas
été confiée à des spécialistes de la
pharmacocinétique ou de la
bioéquivalence il a été confié un
praticiens prescripteurs de génériques
et le groupe de kalemie a choisi
rhumatologue pour deux raisons d'une
part parce que les médicaments de
spécialité en rhumatologie sont très
souvent des génériques est con comme on
dit maintenant et que d'autre part ce
sont des médicaments qu'on utilise à
long terme de façon chronique donc la
surveillance de ses produits de ses
génériques dans ces allégations sont
tout à fait pertinente alors que la
méthode utilisée étaient les suivantes
les trois questions qui avait posé le
bureau de l'académie sont les suivantes
avec quels médicaments at on observé des
plaintes de patients et quelle est la
véracité des pilotes avec quels
médicaments at on observé des signaux
les prescripteurs
c'est à dire vous voyez les deux joies
d'information d'une part les patients et
d'autre part est presque
et bien évidemment comme tous rapports
scientifiques
on a été voir ce qui se passait ailleurs
c'est à dire les autres pays si vous
voulez on a déjà beaucoup évoqué les
résultats de la littérature
internationale donc je serai
relativement bref bon il y a dans la
littérature internationale international
à l'évidence des publications qui montre
des problèmes d'acceptabilité de
non-conformité voir d'efficacité le plus
souvent ce sont des cas individuels
n'est pas toujours quelques fois ce sont
des classes pharmacologiques
mais globalement lorsque l'on regarde le
bilan de ses travaux qui sens
essentiellement les travaux qui ont été
faits à l'amérique du nord
il va rétrospective de rêve déjà sur
plus de 2000 études de bioéquivalence
montrent une bonne concordance entre
paramètres cinétique des princeps et dg
direct donc il n'ya pas de problème à ce
stade là et j'ajoute que pour des
raisons
j'allais dire presque diplomatique nous
avons pris la précaution de mettre un
bibliographie uniquement ils disent et
des génériques utilisant l'amérique du
nord et dont j'ai vérifié qu'il n'avait
pas été utilisée ni en europe ni même en
france par conséquent voyez vous il n'y
avait pas moyen de d'importer
directement en france qui avait été
trouvé mais je pense que le travail qui
consistait à voir d'une part à un
certain nombre d'inconvénients et
ensuite à face on paie résoudre est une
chose intéressante
alors ta conclusion du rapport à vail
est sans ambiguïté elle tire déjà dans
son titre la place des génériques
donc les prescriptions je crois qu'on
peut pas être plus clair et je citerai
simplement la première recommandation
d'académie qui dit effort de pédagogie
il apporte d'expliquer à tous les
acteurs c'est-à-dire aussi bien les
patients et médecins des pharmaciens que
le corps infirmier que les médicaments
génériques sont des équivalents mais qui
ne sont pas forcément identiques et bien
pour bien expliquer par une pédagogie
approprié que ces médicaments peuvent
tout à fait être substituée alors je
voudrais vous le donner quelques
difficultés rencontrées je les je
voudrais d'abord vous parlais des
difficultés de présentation il se trouve
que
je vais ya quelques mois j'ai eu un cas
qui m'a été rapporté par la maison siens
étudiants et qui va je pense vous
expliquer une des réticences de générer
un vieux monsieur dans une maison de
retraite
trois comprimés par jour alors bon il
n'a pas toujours sa tête il sait qu'il
ya à faire
un bleu et rouge il prend 2 vers le
matin donc c'est quand ce matin midi et
soir
il renouvelle son ordonnance son
ordonnance revient donc rail ou vrai
aidé à 3 complet mais blanc il est perdu
et je rejoins ce qu'on dit mes collègues
je pense que dans le meilleur des cas il
n'y a pas une variabilité variations
d'effets mais ils forment obtenu une
si vous voulez là il ya manifestement un
problème de présentation différente qui
désoriente complètement le patient je
veux donner un deuxième exemple qui est
celui d'un comprimé qui remplacé par une
gélule alors ça c'est très très simple
faire un comprimé comprend une poudre et
cette poule on la compresse ces simples
comprimés une autre façon de faire un
générique est beaucoup moins coûteuse
c'est de faire une gélule c'est à dire
qu'on n'a pas besoin de faire un
comprimé mais on est la poudre d'un jus
simplement le volume est plus grand et
un certain nombre de patients se
plaignent que la gélule plus difficile à
avaler
troisième exemple parce que celui là est
peut-être encore un peu plus important
ce sont les comprimés sécables c'est
aussi une observation confiant de
recevoir des comprimés qui sont quadri
ces câbles et le patient est aussi
d'ailleurs le le praticien se plaquent
20 avec eux généré qui n'arrive pas si
j'ose dire a coupé le comprimé en quatre
alors je ne sais pas et ça je me
retourne vers le le directeur de
l'agencé parce que je ne sais pas du
tout s'il ya eu une à l'impératif
réglementaire sur le coup leur sur la
forme pharmaceutique ça peut être une
gélule ou un comprimé mais là
manifestement voyez-vous l'effort
pédagogique il est évident il faut le
faire il faut leur expliquer et à partir
de ce moment là les choses sont plus
simples
alors ça c'était pour la présentation
quelques fois en termes d'excipients je
ne crois pas beaucoup
on a beaucoup parlé d'accident
allergiques en changeant les excipients
c'est peut être vrai personnellement on
n'a pas vu donc théoriquement possible
pratiquement nous n'avons pas
d'expérience en revanche le récemment
alors là j'ai vu dans les journaux mais
c'est peut-être faut que pour des
collyres des génériques de collyre il y
avait un problème de tolérance c'est à
dire que disons que le générique
picotait dans l'oeil
alors que le produit initial semble-t-il
ne me connaît pas et là encore je
voulais je vous le livre brut de
décoffrage l'est pas je n'ai pas vérifié
alors eux ils restent quand même que
pour un certain nombre de médicaments
il ya des problèmes il ya des problèmes
d'acceptabilité et là c'est pas pour
rien qu'on cite à l'heure actuelle les
cinq classes pharmacologiques imac l5
donc pour lesquelles vous avez parlé des
immuno suppresseurs vous avez parlé des
antibiotiques des antiépileptiques des
psychotropes
oui porteuse ha oui des inconnus des
antibiotiques injectables là pour cela
je pense que va la bioéquivalence je
pense qu'on est lui évoluera peut être
un petit peu mais à l'heure actuelle on
peut pas faire mieux
c'est un calcul quand même de cro bat li
té de probabilité qui est vraiment très
très poussée la probabilité c'est pas
une certitude
donc je pense que la prudence c'est que
pour ses produits on fasse spécialement
attention pour ces classes
pharmacologiques
pour les autres il y en eut pas que je
pense que ça n'est pas utile alors ce
que je voudrais vous dire maintenant
c'est que je peux je préfère un bilan
négatif voudrais vous proposer les
solutions chose qu'il ya des solutions
qui sont possibles et la première
solution c'est que chez un même malade
il faut limiter au maximum le changement
de médicaments génériques ou princeps
alors attention je tiens bien préciser
ma position
nous ne sommes pas contre la
substitution bien le contraire mais nous
disons attention ne multiplions pas le
changement de génériques chez un même
patient
pour des raisons évidentes et que
que les mes deux collègues viennent de
présenter c'est que manifestement le
malade va être perdu autrement dit il
faut limiter la substitution limiter les
changements que générique et si possible
donc dispensé toujours le même
médicament alors ne pas changer de
génériques assez facile d'abord dans un
certain nombre de traitements de fond on
peut très bien commencer par le
générique il va par le princeps
ça c'est une première chose la première
évidence mais l'autre qui me paraît
encore plus simple c'est pour le patient
la fidélité aux pharmaciens la fidélité
aux pharmaciens va toujours vers le même
pharmacien
par conséquent le pharmacien si c'est ce
qui lui a donné une première fois il lui
donnera la même chose et je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur une
initiative pharmaceutique n'est pas
encore bien connus mais qui est tout à
fait intéressante
c'est ce qu'on appelle le dossier
pharmaceutique je ne sais pas si on en a
déjà parlé ici dans dance au sénat mais
ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est que
ce dossier pharmaceutique
c'est la possibilité d'enregistrer tous
les médicaments que le patient a reçu
est la possibilité pour le pharmacien de
savoir quasi instantanément quel
médicament a reçu non je ne sais pas là
je parle sous contrôle je ne sais pas si
on peut je pense qu'on peut identifier
le générique bien évidemment sur le par
le numéro du lot de donc vous voyez là
je pense que là encore pédagogie il
devrait pas il devrait pas y avoir de
problème alors fidélité aux pharmaciens
explications détaillées précision
écrites sur l'emballage mais là encore
les précisions écrites sur l'emballage
qui fera l'emballage est perdu on aurait
vu des exemples il faudrait pouvoir
écrire directement sur le blister ça ça
ne se fait pas il faut aussi renforcer
je pense la pharmacovigilance là ça fait
longtemps que je ne fais plus de
pharmacovigilance je ne suis plus au
service de l' agence mais c'est parce
que je suis retraité 1
mais je pense que la femme de dos
la pharmacovigilance des génériques est
une chose aussi tout à fait importantes
c'est-à-dire houllier quand
vous avez un effet indésirable qui
rapportait la femme gisant généralement
il est rapporté par sa dénomination
commune internationale à ce qu'il serait
intéressant c'est d'avoir aussi le
laboratoires génériques
voilà donc ce que je voulais que vous
dire en vous disant que véritablement en
expliquant mieux je pense que on doit
pouvoir faire progresser les génériques
merci monsieur le président je pense que
si le doyen sassard veux ajouter quelque
chose si vous me le permettez après
merci papa la présidente monsieur le
président j'ai pas grand chose à
rajouter même vous exposez milan qui ont
été faits se seraient plus en fin de
compte en termes de déjà vieux malade
que j'aurais exprimer je crois plus dans
ce cas dit déçu dans ce qui a été dit ce
qui est vraiment partant très important
au point de vue pratique c'est que c'est
vrai et c'est pas toujours le cas si la
présentation du générique peut être la
même que le princeps ça simplifiera
beaucoup on voit battant beaucoup de
génériques qui sont tous sous forme de
blister et mettez vous à la place de la
personne d'un certain âge même cas
encore sa tête qu'un truc pour la
prostate un tube pensons que les stérols
un truc pour sa tension et c'est trois
trucs blanc présenté un bistrot range
ses sources de confusion et ça c'est pas
très très compliqué à obtenir
la deuxième chose sur laquelle le
presseur tivement insisté c'est que
quand un générique est donné qu'un
malade est équilibré avec un générique
qu'il ne change pas de générique car qui
ne passe pas d'un générique de marque x
pour un générique de marque y
le dossier pharmaceutique peut aider
c'est comme avec un princeps je pense
que les malades sont équilibrés d'une
façon avec un médicament
eh bien il faut qu'il le garde sur le
plan de la bioéquivalence qui était la
question vous aviez posé au préalable et
là je m'exprimerai à titre personnel
parce que je crains tu pas être suivi il
ya deux choses qu'il pose un petit peu
de souci c'est la définition de la
bioéquivalence telle qu'elle est donnée
dans les textes pour quelqu'un qui a
fait un tout petit peu de pharmacologie
clinique
j'avoue que j'ai bien regardé l est
strictement enfin bon je suis pas rival
à comprendre donc pour un individu moyen
et les non compréhensibles
alors que si on arrive à dire parce que
je crois que c'est la réalité des choses
que quand on donne un comprimé de
génériques par voie orale à la place
d'un comprimé princeps
les concentrations de la molécule active
dans le sang les concentrations maximum
observé le moment auquel ils sont
observés
la durée de temps pendant laquelle sont
servis sont à plus ou moins 5% du
princeps dans les choses seraient
claires et ça serait un argument qui
permettrait en changeant simplement
cette définition de beaucoup mieux
argumenter vis-à-vis du public vis-à-vis
des professionnels médecins généralistes
comme pharmacien la substitution donc un
changement définition c'est une opinion
personnelle dont qui n'engage que moi
bien sûr et la deuxième pignon
personnelle qui n'engage que moi et je
suis content de faire devant monsieur
marc allain qui sait que avec les
délocalisations les contrôles peuvent
aussi être délocalisé les contrôles de
bioéquivalence peuvent éventuellement
être fait dans des conditions qui ne
sont pas tout à fait optimale et sans
être de très loin un partisan de la
réglementation et de très très loin
je pense que l'agrément donné un certain
nombre de structures de pharmacologie
clinique qui ferait si contrôle de
bioéquivalence que ce soit pour l'europe
pour les états unis pour l'asie mais un
contrôle des structures de contrôle la
bioéquivalence pourrait peut-être évité
quelques distorsions qui quand même on
existe et je remercie
merci monsieur martin qui vous ajouter
quelque chose je vous permettez je
voudrais quand même prendre un ou
commenter un certain nombre de ses
points
dans la compréhension de l'ensemble
vous voyez que nous nous oscillons entre
du vécu du ressenti et de l'objectif et
c'est vrai qu'en thérapeutiques en
médecine
ça peut arriver mais cependant tout de
même il faut pas en faire la cie de une
cible particulière sur le générique je
voudrais rappeler que les médicaments
génériques sont un bien qui ont permis
de voix nier et de guérir des millions
de personnes dans le monde et notamment
parce qu'ils sont moins chers et
notamment parce qu'ils sont de très
bonne qualité et nous ça n'a pas été dit
mais je me permets de le dire en tant
que responsable et en tant que personne
il ya d'énormes enjeux économiques
autour des génériques entre eux et entre
les princeps et les génériques et que ça
peut fausser un tout petit peu le débat
et la compréhension
quelques remarques il faut pas être
militant il faut être objectif il est
vrai que le concept de bioéquivalence on
peut paraître abstrait et l'idée pour un
pharmacologue rappelons nous que pour
nous c'est pas un concept c'est un texte
réglementaire opposable aux siens qui
nous permet de vérifier point par point
les expériences qui ont été réalisés et
de leur refuser une autorisation si ces
expériences dont les textes
réglementaires de qualité fins
scientifiques ou pharmaceutiques non
c'est vrai n'ont pas vocation à être
compréhensible sauf par ceux à qui
s'opposent c'est comme quand on définit
l'assurance qualité de frein automobile
enfin gros c'est fait pour freiner il
prédit sûr que ça marche il faut être
sûr que le fabricant va respecter le
cailly le cahier des charges et donc et
c'est vrai pour ces textes là sont les
mêmes d'ailleurs qu'il s'agisse de
princeps ou de génériques par rapport à
nos collègues je suis aussi médecin
praticien mais nous devons évoluer dans
notre culture de médicaments même si
c'est encore le cas
nous consommons peut-être parfois trop
de médicaments et parfois de façon
inappropriée et les reconnaître à la
couleur est toujours dangereux est
toujours dangereux parce que les
couleurs peuvent changer ou la visionner
un médicament
voilà donc il faut que on se rappelle up
la surveillance de la prise de
médicaments
l'esquissé de l'observance mais c'est
aussi la surveillance et la remise en
question permanente de leurs effets
thérapeutiques
qu'il s'agisse d'un prince est soudain
ou d'un produit générique
donc le fait de doses et des hormones
thyroïdiennes qu'en donne un traitement
substitutif est un acte médical banal
qu'il s'agit d'un quel que soit le
produit
je ferai une remarque quand même sur le
fait qu'en commençant générique il faut
pas le changer par nature quand on
change du générique on veut on continue
on reste dans la même substance active
la législation le permet maintenant et
merci aux législateurs de l'avoir fait
vous savez c'est une grosse bataille
pour lutter contre les brevets parce que
tout est breveté la couleur le grain le
glisse terre etc
il est permis maintenant ça a été
tranchée de faire exactement la même
présentation entre les produits
voilà est-ce que les firmes vont le
faire
c'est pour des ce sont des raisons
compliquées nous nous le souhaitons et
l'ensemble de
des parlementaires à voter un texte qui
est important il faut qu'il soit
appliqué et que nous soyons incitatif et
puis il faut aussi un peu du bon sens
médical comme nous l'avons tous
peut-être que comme l'enjeu est
économique
il ne faut pas essayer de violer des
situations médicales un peu dramatique
quand vous avez une greffe de coeur
depuis cinq ans et qu'on vous dit prenez
prenez prenez votre immunosuppresseurs
scission vous le changez vous pourrez
être un peu bouleversé parce que vous
savez que si vous arrêtez votre produit
votre greffe on va partir donc là aussi
dans les politiques de substitution qui
sont parfaitement respectable dans le
cadre de la politique de de santé on
peut de modérer un peu de bon sens dans
les obligations de substitution peut
donner une meilleure acceptabilité
sociale ou médicale d'autant parfois
l'enjeu économique peut y être meilleur
je voudrais dire aussi aux futurs pros
finir que la politique de génériques
française est un succès et c'est
peut-être pour ça que ça commence
attendre maintenant nous notre pays est
toujours et parfois un peu masochiste
nous sommes le pays qui donne le plus
bas et même avec le plus de rigueur et
pourquoi nous donnons beaucoup
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
c'est parce que les industriels savent
que nos autorisations de mise sur le
marché sont considérées comme très
sérieuse par les autres par les autres
pays et donc ils peuvent vendre des
génériques de bonne qualité deuxièmement
la substitution elle commence à se faire
et nous devons lutter en permanence
contre la désinformation
puisque vous avez mentionné le fait que
notre système du médicament y surveiller
oui les surveiller et quand quand il ya
un défaut qualité qu'il s'agit d'un
générique ou dans l'eau ou du nom
générique
tous les lots sont bloqués dont le
système pharmaceutique français avec son
système d'officine et le système du
dossier pharmaceutique est un système
extrêmement puissant qui permet de
tracer tous les produits que prennent
tous les malades
nous en sommes servis en a plusieurs
reprise par contre nous devons changer
de culture sur reconnaître le comprimé
rouge du comprimé je sais pas sûr que ce
soit le même principe actif comme vous
le savez ouais et donc on devrait aller
dans le bon sens notre principale
crainte nous ne sommes pas là pour faire
la publicité tous les médicaments se
valent ou ne se valent pas et quand ils
se valent pas il faut qu'on les supprime
qu'ils soient cher ou pas cher par
contre ce qui est dangereux c'est la
perte de confiance et le risque de
désinformation qui se fait pour des
intérêts qui sont le plus souvent
économique quand même il faut pas se le
cacher que objectif peut-être monsieur
astier voulait encore intervenir après
on passera aux questions oui oui
messieurs présents juste un point sur ce
qui vient d'être dit deux remarques
on n'a pas parlé de la prescription par
dénomination commune internationale
chose qui règlerait beaucoup de
problèmes qui d'ailleurs est prévue par
la loi donc théoriquement ça devrait
régler ensemble de problèmes
deuxièmement en tant que pharmacien
hospitalier les génériques c'est un
problème qu'on ne connaît pas puisque on
les utilise depuis qu'ils existent et le
patient à l'hôpital le prescripteur à
l'hôpital même qu'il presqu'un immuno
suppresseurs une fois c'est le générique
une fois c'est le princeps
à ma connaissance il ne s'est jamais
passé le moindre problème hein sinon ça
se saurait vous pensez bien que s'il ya
eu des morts l'hôpital henri mondor liés
à des substitutions de médicaments
génériques ça serait donc voilà des
éléments qui montrent que finalement
même sur des produits à marge
thérapeutique étroite théoriquement
alors ce qui n'empêche pas effectivement
de prendre ensemble de précautions dans
des cas tout à fait particulier mais là
une politique ne s'est pas sur des cas
particuliers et je considère que la
collectivité doit quand même se poser
des questions est ce qu'on doit
finalement ne voir que les cas
particuliers on doit quand même voir
l'ensemble et compte tenu des économies
réalisées par les génériques et ce qui
pourrait être encore réalisé par les
génériques
je pense que la question est close
je propose de donner la parole donc g3
demande la présidente de la commission
de la sociale ont mis ensuite monsieur
savary donc c'est un tour dans la marne
et messieurs c'est à tort la moselle
après monsieur barbier donc quatre
questions on les prend les quatre
oui merci monsieur le président merci
messieurs pour votre présentation
et je voudrais remercier
particulièrement yves daudigny parce que
c'est vrai que le programme de notre mec
c'est assez chargé cette année est
d'avoir réussi à trouver un peu de temps
pour organiser ces deux tableaux rende
cet après midi je trouve ça très
intéressant parce que c'est un sujet
vous le savez qui est sensible au sein
de notre commission et il me semblait
important qu'on puisse le réaliser donc
malgré notre travail chargé on a trouvé
le temps de le faire et c'est tant mieux
donc je voulais j'avais juste question
de quelques questions un peu mélangé
peut-être pour l'ensemble des personnes
qui sont intervenues vous nous vous nous
avez parlé donc de cette bio équivalence
et du coût des tests de bioéquivalence
qui sont mises en oeuvre pour pouvoir
apporter la sécurité à nos médicaments
et génériques
ne pensez-vous pas que du coup pour
c'est peut-être que je devrais vous
préciser aussi que je suis comme ça a
été un peu dit par plutôt favorables à
la politique de médicaments génériques
comme ça les choses se seront seront
claires dans mes questions je suis
plutôt favorable à cette politique du
médicament générique mais du coup en
s'assurant de sa bonne qualité comme
l'ensemble d'entre vous ici messieurs
donc pour ces tests de bio qui
équivalence qui sont faits ne
pensez-vous pas du coup que pour
apporter plus de pour être mieux
rassurer finalement d'un point de vue
tant des patients que des professionnels
qui doivent se prescrire ensuite ses
génériques
il lui aurait nécessité à avoir un peu
plus de transparence sur ces comme ça se
fait pour d'autres tests un peu plus de
transparence il a beaucoup été question
jusqu'à maintenant de répertoire
notamment pensez-vous pas par exemple
qu'un répertoire sur ces tests de
bioéquivalence permettrait justement de
savoir si comme ça a été dit certains
tests de bioéquivalence sont délocalisés
mais en soirée où sont faits ces tests
on aurait les résultats de ces tests et
ça permettrait comme ça de rassurer un
petit peu tout le monde sur
la bonne tenue et la bonne validité de
ces tests de bioéquivalence et du coup
quelle danse et est quelle est la mesure
des excipients puisque il y à aussi j'ai
bien compris enfin me semble-t-il que
ces tests se faisait principalement sur
la molécule active mais est-ce que les
des excipients sont également pris en
compte et quelles sont ses impacts et
comment sont-ils répertoriés dans ses
tests de de bioéquivalence par rapport
aux ensuite à la fabrication de ces
médicaments génériques
j'ai bien compris aussi que la
fabrication était fait dans de bonnes
conditions mais sommes nous certains de
la bonne qualité par exemple des
matières premières qui vont rentrer dans
la fabrication de ces de ses génériques
ensuite vous nous avez dit qu'il n'y a
aucune étude qui dit que ses génériques
sont moins efficaces
mais y at il des études qui nous disent
qu'ils sont au moins aussi efficace donc
très bien s'il y en a vous allez me le
dire et par rapport aux à l'effort de
pédagogie moi je suis je suis persuadé
effectivement que la pédagogie pourra
nous permettre d'améliorer la vente de
nos médicaments génériques
est ce que vous ne pensez pas puisque
nous avons ici l'académie nationale de
médecine est ce que vous ne pensez pas
que par exemple dans la formation des
médecins un peu de quoi peut-être ça
c'est déjà vous allez me répondre
messieurs un peu de connaissances
notamment fin de connaissance un peu
plus de 2 de connaissance d'un point de
vue
pharmacologiques et puis également dans
la dans l'idée de la de la pédagogie je
rejoins ce que vous disiez par rapport à
la dénomination commune la dci est ce
qui ne serait pas intéressant aussi
d'inviter nos médecins a plutôt
prescrire sous cette dénomination
commune plutôt que sous le nom d'un
médicament puisque en effet ça favorise
généralement le princeps eux plutôt que
le générique
voilà ensuite juste peut-être une petite
réflexion sur la couleur des médicaments
monsieur marc anaky autant je veux bien
entendre que effectivement il ne faut
pas reconnaître un médicament à sa
couleur mais en même temps je partage un
peu ce qui a été dit pour connaître
autour de moi pas mal de personnes
malheureusement
voilà qui sont dans la nécessité de
prendre plusieurs traitements et il est
vrai que lorsque les médicaments change
d'aspect un peu trop souvent ou de tout
simplement parfois de couleur mais delà
du comprimé à la gélule aussi ça arrive
ça déstabilise beaucoup certains malades
et ça n'incite pas du coup a accepté
lorsque les pharmaciens nous propose la
substitution par des génériques ça ne
cite pas les patients à accepter cette
substitution s'il ya trop de changements
fréquents et dans le médicament lui-même
et ensuite dans la forme sous laquelle
est prescrit ce médicament
voilà je vous remercie monsieur merci
monsieur savary à prendre toute la
batterie de questions
oui quelques remarques et quelques
questions pratiques en tant que médecin
généraliste vous avez parlé de 2,2 de
l'empathie avec laquelle il fallait
effectivement prescrire le générique la
pédagogie a été soulignée par madame
d'allied mais il ya aussi
un argument très convaincant c'est le
remboursement la sécurité sociale qui a
pris la décision de ne plus faire le
tiers payant dès l'instant où le malade
refusé le générique je peux vous dire
c'est d'une redoutable efficacité
je crois que ce sont des mesures comme
ça qu'il faut prendre comme par hasard
ils acceptent le générique dès l'instant
où il a pu le tiers payant donc
véritablement c'est un argument qu'il
faut véritablement me semble-t-il
consolidé pour faire changer les
mentalités et elles changent vite un
deuxième argument le changement
effectivement les pharmaciens d'un mois
sur l'eau dans le renouvellement même de
leur donne ans ne donne pas le même
générique
alors ça c'est la faille tonnes le
générique mais d'un autre laboratoire
1 selon les prises alors là dessus
peut-être que nous aurions ddd chose à
faire parce que c'est là où il ya tous
les problèmes c'est véritablement là
qu'il faut trouver une solution parce
que les malades sont paumés complètement
moi je suis sur une sidéré même je
trouve qu'ils s'y retrouvent pas trop
mal a encore fait même surpris noire
elle comment ils arrivent à s'y
retrouver dans dans ces choses là
troisième point troisième point
également un élément pratique derrière
avec la multiplicité des génériques vous
l'avez dit ça fait à peu près neuf mille
principes actifs hors penser aux
logiciels des médecins moi je viens de
faire informé le cair informatisé de
cabinet médical
les logiciels sont de plus en plus
compliqué mais ça devient aberrant dans
les amoxicilline vous en avez deux pages
d'amoxicilline allée des dosages selon
les laboratoires messin pense et on va
demander aux gens de faire de la bonne
médecine on va leur faire perdre leur
temps à choisir les génériques là-dedans
exr qu'on arrête là dessus vous avez
peut-être quelque chose à faire on a
peut-être des choses à faire pour faire
en sorte que ces logiciels soient des
logiciels pratiques et qu'on tombe pas
dans la démesure au type de la
sécurisation à vouloir mettre tous les
laboratoires parce que comme il y en
aura toujours des nouveaux on n'en sort
pas et ça fait neuf mille neuf mille
molécule dans lequel il faut choisir
pour faire une ordonnance pas vous la
faites à la main vous n'avez pu la faire
c'est pas la peine c'est pas la peine
vous passez votre temps à aller chercher
les trucs donc faut revenir à un petit
peu de cohérence
et puis quatrième point ça rejoint ce
que disait madame david sur la formation
des étudiants
là aussi vous avez un rôle nous avons un
rôle comment se fait-il que quand votre
malade est hospitalisée qui part avec un
traitement de génériques qui sort avec
une ordonnance de sortie de l'hôpital
avec un jeu une ordonnance de 2,2
princeps quelque chose qui va pas quoi
c'est quand même pas si dur que ça que
les chefs de service inculque à l'heure
à l'heure alors non il faut encore les
ordonnances à la main les hôpitaux est
en mission pour logiciel mail ou même
d'un alalalala qui sont encore dans neuf
hôpitaux sur dix alors de lens
alairacois égale qui qu'ils soient qui
est tatillon tifa ça que les internes
puisque c'est les internes qui font les
ordonnances derrière quoi qu'il ya des
ordres du chef de service de faire
quelque chose de pratique et puis de
suivre un peu un certain nombre de
choses
bon voilà je pense que ya pas de besoin
de changements fondamentaux mais
simplement maintenant de petits
changements pratiques qui permettraient
là aussi de gagner j'en suis sûr dans
l'utilisation des génériques merci
monsieur leroy oui je vous remercie
d'avoir organisé cette réunion est agité
des sénateurs qui ne font pas partie de
la commission de social pour ma part
j'ai été interpellé par les génériques
parce que je suis un malade en longue
maladie je sais pas quoi
lorsqu'on m'a fait on m'a fait des
pompes on a fait des pontages et donc
depuis 12 ans je prends des médicaments
ne sont pas trop nombreux et jusqu'à
présent j'ai pas souffert des des
pilules a fallu leur changement de
couleur mais même moi qui prends trois
pilules par jour
je suis encore à moitié
intellectuellement vahid canton de
change les médicaments ça me trouble
enfin quand on me change là la forme des
médicaments parce que j'avale ce à toute
allure le matin et parce que je suis en
retard et donc ça peut poser quelques
fois qu'elle me ceci dit je suis pas
contre les gêner mais je suis aussi
agronome à l'origine est donc gg j'étais
habitué aux fio aux phytosanitaires donc
à la manipulation des molécules
complexes ce qui ce qui m'inquiète c'est
un au plan fondamental
c'est que le princeps je suis désolé
enfin mes connaissances en chimie sont
celles d'un hold up mais princeps et un
peu de l'alchimie ce qui existent sont
des molécules les molécules
or le le le principe c'est à dire le
médicament d'origine celui qui a eu les
brevets celui qui a subi tous les tests
celui à partir des bsa pense quelques
voix 6 8 ans on trouve qu'à un ton un
tel médicament est un bon médicament et
son appel seul princeps
il se trouve que ces copies c'est copier
je ne parle pas des excipients
je parle bien de la molécule initial
ces copies ne sont pas des ne ressemble
pas tout à la molécule initial vous ne
pouvez pas le garantir
aucune il faut y regarder celle des jeux
jolie je suis chimiste un tout petit peu
pas du tout médecin mais je peux vous
dire que la molécule qui a fait l'objet
de tous les contrôles et qui est qu'on a
reconnu au bout de six ou huit ans qu'on
aurait connu comme une molécule efficace
elle été efficace et a été présentée
sous forme de je ne sais quoi alginate
de je ne sais quoi
et puis tout d'un coup dans les copies
on va trouver le thème que j'utilisais
peut-être idiot à saly sicat de la même
chose mais c'est plus la même molécule
ont pas ceux plus bêtement s'ils ont des
temps chimie minérale d'un d'un chlorure
à sulfate on change la molécule donc ce
qui me choque ou plan fondamental c'est
que la molécule qu'on prescrit n'est pas
toujours la même c'est le même principe
mais c'est pas toujours le même c'est
lula mais là ça me choque un peu ça me
choque d'autant plus que vous avez dit
que les copies les génériques ne font
pas l'objet de tests cliniques ont fait
les zestes de bio équivalence qui sont à
la fois fondée sur des principes
scientifiques évidemment
diffusion dont l'organisme etc mais
aussi des des critères juridiques la
bioéquivalence et juridique aux
scientifiques
elle n'est pas scientifique donc c'est
d'une deuxième inquiétude de napa et
j'aurais souhaité qu'on aille plus loin
dans les analyses voudrait probablement
déjà réfléchi à la question
mais c'est une question qui m'intéresse
comme ex scientifique j'étais à l'ina je
me suis pas du tout spécialisé dans la
médecine déduites aisée des êtres à sang
chaud mais la médecine des végétaux je
connais un peu et je vous promets que
lis ici à 2-2 interrogation fondamentale
que j'ai et que je souhaite vous
indiquer pour les médecins et les
pharmaciens je peux à terme et il faut
que ce serait des clous ces intervenants
puissent répondre à une question c'est
pourquoi les médecins et les pharmaciens
ne s'entendent pas simplement parce que
pour prescrire le même produit de base
par exemple après aux pharmaciens de
jouer pourquoi ils s'entendent pas
j'avoue que enfin ils s'entendent pas
pourquoi on à ces divergences le médecin
prescrit quelque chose de pharmaciens
prescrit autre chose ça serait tellement
plus simple de prescrire un princeps
ensuite aux pharmaciens princeps et son
dosage ensuite aux pharmaciens de cholet
mais là on a des vraies questions et
merci de m'avoir écouté mais bravo à la
commission c'est bien j'ai vu monsieur
mamane un clic qui prenait des notes
donc on aura des réponses très précises
sur ces questions dont s'il vous plaît
moi j'aime pas trop faire la police mais
il y 40 2
si nous souhaitons avoir des réponses
vrai que nous puissions concentrer un
peu les questions monsieur barbier
j'ai posé une seule question qui
intéresse l'académie de médecine et puis
monsieur marc anaky c'est cette problème
de substitution qui coûte plus de 500
millions par an à la sécurité sociale à
savoir l'utilisation l'avastin dans la
démêlera par rapport au juste senti ce
qui coûte 40 fois plus cher apparemment
un certain nombre d'écoles de médecine
notamment de lyon pour expérimenter le
l'avastin non dans ce en injectant une
série de patients avec des résultats qui
semblent satisfaisants il semble que
l'académie de médecine a trouvé qu'il y
avait un petit problème quelquefois une
réaction plus ou moins déterminé ce que
c'est pas simplement un problème de
relation entre les deux laboratoires
producteurs pour les sites et novartis
et roche qui sont quand même très
proches l'un de l'autre pour défendre ce
qui est une exception française
c'est le la non substitution du lucentis
par l'avastin r c'est monsieur barbier
madame claire oui merci
désolé je suis arrivé un petit peu tard
donc j'ai pas entendu les propos
introductifs moi je voudrais quand on
arrive à la fin finalement il ya moins
de questions posées en ré ré insisté sur
le fait que en france
la france reçoit le deuxième pays où le
prix des génériques est le plus élevé
donc je voudrais avoir votre sentiment
là dessus pour voir finalement quelles
peuvent être les les leviers pour éviter
ce genre ce genre de choses deuxième
question c'est pas ça a été dit par
rapport au générique le fait que
finalement les contrôles ne soit pas
suffisamment poussées et donc ce qui a
entraîné un certain nombre
deux professionnels a dénoncé dénoncé le
fait que les contrôles n'étaient pas
n'était pas suffisamment complet par
rapport aux médicaments de base
monique hulot mais l'équipe de base donc
qu'en est il exactement
et la troisième question que je voudrais
poser c'est que effectivement donc la
politique qui est menée concernant les
génériques est tout à fait intéressante
ceci étant dit il y à un certain nombre
de deux réactions qui sont parfois
diverses en ce sens où des
professionnels y compris disent que sur
certains individus
effectivement le générique va avoir
moins d'effet que le comment vous
appelez seul princeps bon donc je pense
que ça doit varier d'un individu à
l'autre très certainement mais c'est
aussi intéressant d'avoir votre avis sur
cette question parce que parfois comme
patient on peut se sentir un peu
contraint et du coup mal mal conseillé
par rapport à la prise de tel ou tel
médicament
merci la première question plutôt pour
la deuxième table sur la question
française donc des prix doit de la sur
les aspects scientifiques la question
sera abordée après midi monsieur le
sénateur milan j'ai pas dis docteur
merci monsieur le président bon tout
toutes les questions qui ont été posées
étaient intéressantes j'ai trouvé pour
moi ce qui me concerne la plus
intéressante celle de monsieur leroy et
je voudrais je voulais revenir sur sur
une expérience je vais essayer d'être
rapide président une dame qui prend un
certain nombre de traitements 70 ans est
traité pour des problèmes gastriques
années comme acteur elle est soignée
elle en guérit
elle va revoir son médecin qui lui a
prescrit son ordonnance habituel en
oubliant en pression par ton qui sont
dans dix ans habituels et elle va
surseoir masia le pharmacien mais les
génériques en place un générique en
place dans là dedans la série des
médicaments elle s'en aperçoit pas elle
prend ses médicaments elle a à nouveau
mal à l'estomac
à tel point d'ailleurs que le médecin
traitant décide de refaire des examens
pour rechercher une recrudescence de
l'hélicoptère et on ne trouve rien elle
va voir son médecin son décès n'y a rien
à votre estomac sais pas pourquoi vous
ai mal mais a rien d'autre à ce moment
je vous refais votre ordonnance et puis
on verra dans quelques temps si ça
marche et en refaisant l'audience ils
oublient l'un des médicaments et il se
trouve que en oubliant ce médicament à
la dame n'a plus mal à l'estomac
elle se rend compte qu'elle a pu mât
l'estomac elle prend le médicament qui a
été oubliée elle va voir son médecin et
il ne lui dit et lui dit je sais pas en
tout cas j'ai vous inscrire vous le
reprenez plus on verra bien il y aura
près ce qui est le maître et le
pharmacien la lui redonne le médicament
princeps et elle a plus mal à l'estomac
s'il ya une bioéquivalence parce qu'elle
est en fait manger avec le collègue
médecin regarder le médicament seul même
évidemment voilà bien une bioéquivalence
la faille c'est le même principe actif
c'est le même celle mais il ya donc un
problème il ya quand même un problème et
et honnêtement je ne pense pas un seul
instant que ce soit du psychosomatique
parce que la dame ne s'était pas du tout
aperçu que le médicament avait été
remplacé par un générique
absolument pas donc je pose la question
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir quand même de
temps en temps avec générique d des
problèmes là y en a un et je vous assure
cette dame c'est ma femme elle ne
s'était absolument pas perçu et moi non
plus qu' il y avait un générique qui
remplaçait le principe le médicament
d'avant
ainsi derrière question de bâton oui
merci de me donner la parole j'ai fait
faire part d'une expérience personnelle
puisque moi j'étais vétérinaire de
clientèle rurale un jour ian un client
qui m'appellent et il avait 22 cochon
qui était malade me déterminer la
maladie joue pas savoir faire porter un
diagnostic juste et j'avais l'habitude
de faire dans ce cas n'a une solution
injectable dans piscine et de colistine
le mélange de ces deux antibiotiques qui
fonctionne bien et c
et puis comme dans ma voiture je n'avais
plus cette solution dans piscine
colistine injectables j'ai pris un
flacon dans piscine et un flacon de
colistine et j'ai décidé de leur faire
une piqûre de colistine d'un côté une
piqûre dans piscine de l'autre et on
avait l'habitude de vagues de de faire
des injections à ses 22 cochon lorsque
je suis arrivé au huitième ou neuvième
cochon j'étais en train de piquer 8e je
me retourne et je vois le premier paf
raid
je dis merde il était malade j'ai dit
aux gars mon client qui est un bon
client bon copain je dis il était
malade insulaire
je pique le suivant le 9e 10 2 merde
j'ai dit attends on va peut-être arrêter
de les piquer alors j'étais arrivé au
10e et je les ai vus sous mes yeux
tatata ptac 10 au tapis 10 au tapis
alors je me suis interrogé alors que
j'avais l'habitude de manipuler ces deux
antibiotiques etc
je me suis interrogé et puis je me suis
dit ça mais pas très longtemps mais
c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs pour
mesurer on peut mesurer la diffusion du
médicament à l'intérieur puisque j'ai
pris ma seringue et j'ai injecté gpg
pompée dans mon flacon de colistine et
l'autre moitié dans piscine dans la même
seringue et immédiatement il s'est formé
un caillou comme un morceau de ciment
bahamas ring et donc
j'ai conclu évidemment que le même
caillou se formait quand les deux
médicaments piqué d'un côté du cou et de
l'autre se rejoignent et ça faisait un
caillou dans le cochon et crack
il était mort ce qui veut dire que tout
ça n'est pas neutre tout ça n'est pas
neutre et en médecine vétérinaire par
exemple les exceptions ça compte
énormément
on a manipulé beaucoup d'antibiotiques
par exemple les tétracyclines notamment
des tests tracy clean à 20%
lorsqu'elle était dans un excipient de
polyvinyle pironi donne c'est une
spécialité de chez fiser la thérapie
ciblant de l'action dans les
d'excellents résultats
quand on mettait des tétracycline à 20 %
dans l'aude en du propylène glycol ça
n'a pas du tout le même effet et le même
effet retard recherchait donc
l'excipient peut tuer aussi et puis
dernière question dernière question est
ce que dans les raviolis findus le
cheval est un générique du boeuf alors
toute une série de questions messieurs
je prenais le temps qu'il vous faut pour
répondre parce que toutes les questions
étaient dignes d'intérêt alors il ya des
questions très fondamentale et d'autres
qui sont plus au niveau de la foi et
donc je ne commenterai pas sur la foi
dans tel ou tel
approche mais il ya lesquels sont très
fondamentale je voudrais essayer de
reprendre le et de re synthétiser cette
problématique de la bioéquivalence
sortons essayons de tuer aussi quand
même un peu les dont je suis très
content tout le monde parle de la
bioéquivalence entre parenthèses je ne
sais pas qui glisse qui a parlé de la
bioéquivalence pour les produits
princeps
j'ai été élevé en pharmacologie aussi je
vous signale que on travaille aussi sur
la butte sa belle biodisponibilité et
qu'il ya des variations
interindividuelles excusez moi monsieur
je m'énerve mais nous ne sommes pas
égaux il ya des variations
interindividuelles en termes de
distribution d'absorption et ce qu'on
fait de la bioéquivalence ça signifie
que on compare sur des individus et on
accepte cette variabilité comme
acceptable donc la bioéquivalence c'est
quelque chose de très sérieux
je me suis mal fait compris puisque on
m'a dit que c'était juridique
non je dis c'est opposable sur le plan
réglementaire puisque c'est quand même
important d'avoir des nôtres on ne peut
avoir la foi mais il faut avoir aussi
des motions précise un millimètre 7,1 mm
et c'est pas juste un petit bout d'os
les définitions opposable sont
extrêmement précises et c'est très
important pour garantir l'équité de par
rapport à toutes les analyses
je crois qu'il faut qu' aucun doute à ce
niveau là à propos des excipients
nombreux débats sur les excipients les
excipients existe dans tous les
médicaments les excipients route ont de
temps en temps des ce qu'on appelle des
effets notoires alors excusez-moi 6
interne un peu
pharmaco mai et des équipements qui ont
pas d'effets de roquetoire et y en a
d'autres qui ont des effets du toit
c'est à dire qu'ils induisent des
allergies chez les personnes allergiques
qu'il s'agisse d'un princeps ou d'un
générique
voilà quelques temps quand c'est très
sucré ben c'est important de savoir
quand les diabétiques et quant à une
allergie un excipient il faut faire très
attention quel que soit le produit même
si ça peut paraître un peu lourdaud ce
que je vous dis c'est pour çà croire à
la couleur du comprimé faut faire
attention à dans tous les principes
actifs excipients cas dans un produit il
peut y avoir un des grandes variations
donc les excipients sont traités et pour
répondre à la question de madame la
présidente
celle on fait très attention a examiné
la totalité du problème chez l'homme
dans la bioéquivalence puisque on étudie
le produit avec son équipe y en en vie
réelle
d'accord donc c'est ya le princeps
versus le générique avec son équipe y en
il faut que la distribution et la
biodisponibilité soit identique aussi
médiocres aussi bonne mais en tous les
cas strictement identiques
donc si nip donc la biodisponibilité
c'est pas des tests au rabais si les
tests importants
c'est comme quand on regarde un dossier
sur un princeps comme si on disait que
finalement la répartition la
biodisponibilité sais pas si terrible
que ça là aussi on est très précis il ya
des variations
il ya des intervalles de confiance
opposable et tous les praticiens qui
sont là et puis on a beaucoup
témoignages qui nous laisse penser que
nous avons tous des variabilité
interindividuelle nous ne sommes pas
tous les mêmes bons les cochons salaire
de spécial mais supporte mal le poison
j'ai l'impression mais mais là il yn'a
n'est pas question donc à ce niveau là
voilà il faut le rendre populaire mais
il faut le rendre populaire aussi pour
les princes est d'accord c'est à dire la
pharmacologie
c'est pareil sur le chalet princesse je
suis pas un chimiste et je laisserai le
mon collègue de l'académie mais je
voudrais quand même rappeler enfin
j'imagine c'est pareil pour les
phytosanitaires qu'il ya des problèmes
de stabilité dans les principes actifs
et que quand on travaille on travaille
sur la molécule est que sur les produits
chimiques qui sont moléculaire mans
identique est stable au cours du temps
que ça soit un princesse ou que ça soit
où que ce soit un générique
n'oubliez pas qu'un princeps les
conditions de fabrication peuvent varier
au cours du temps et que les contrôles
de qualité qui sont faits et je pense
c'est pareil j'espère des
phytosanitaires et ou pesticides on
vérifie qu'il n'y a pas de dérive dans
la conformation moléculaire qui
effectivement une grande influence dans
le futur c'est fait pour les médicaments
les médicaments princeps comme les
médicaments génériques
il faut c'est très bien parce qu'on
discute beaucoup de lacs du contrôle de
qualité pour les génériques mais sache
ça nous donne une pédagogie pour savoir
que pour les autres médicaments c'est
pareil et il faut aussi les contrôler il
ya parfois des pharmaciens mais pas
parfois il ya toujours des pharmaciens
et responsables qui sont pénalement
responsables d'une dérive de fabrication
ils bloquent les lots ils sont
indépendants du
du président de la société si jamais ils
considèrent que la fabrication à des
contrôles de qualité ne sont pas
suffisants donc c'est pas optimum
peut-être la sécurisation du médicament
mais y'a pas pour l'instant est pas
grave il n'y a pas beaucoup
il n'y a pas beaucoup mieux enfin on que
des pires dans beaucoup d'autres
secteurs de ça des produits de santé je
voudrais citer des dispositifs médicaux
ou le niveau de contrôle sont beaucoup
moins rigoureux en tout cas c'est pareil
pour les génériques prend le nom
générique c'est sûr faire des études
d'efficacité pour des raisons
psychologiques et d'acceptabilité
sociale
moi je veux bien mais c'est un problème
d'argent de la collectivité
voilà où vérifier qu'un phytosanitaires
est toujours un phytosanitaires pourquoi
pas mais c'est délicat pour nous en tous
les cas de considérer qu'il faut
mobiliser des ressources pour vérifier
que l'eau et de l'eau enfin bon non le
faire en contrôle qualité mais on peut
pas le faire en deux façons
scientifiquement relevantes et ça serait
quand même une mobilisation de
ressources importantes je néglige pas
l'importance qu'il faut faire pour
rétablir la confiance mais faisons
attention aussi de ne pas trop en
rajouter parce qu'on peut laisser planer
de plus en plus de doutes et en tous les
cas
faisons la même chose si jamais nous
devions le faire et non mobilisés
faisons la même chose pour les principes
que nous notre devoir c'est de traiter
avec équité tous les médicaments
ils doivent être tous aussi bons et donc
si on a le moins bon et l'expérience
prouve que ça peut changer entre les
divers médicaments donc essayer de
sortir la crispation du problème
générique mais concentrons-nous sur la
sécurité du médicament
je suis déjà en répondant ainsi à la
question du sénateur
monsieur barbier est sûre sur la
question de l'avastin versus le lucentis
c'est une question très intéressante à
bien sûr et et passionnante
premièrement il s'agit pas de générique
les génériques concerne les molécules
chimiques et si le président le
souhaitent ou madame la présidente
nous serons amenés un jour à parler
d'autres produits qui s'appelle les
biosimilaires
c'est con hein produits de
biotechnologie c'est pas le cas un temps
l'un produits de biotechnologie et
puisque vous allez discuter financer nos
finances nationales sachez qu'il ya des
biosimilaires qui sont autorisés en
france qui sont très peu utilisés parce
qu'ils sont pas bien compris et que nous
allons
publié un rapport sur ce sujet et que
nous venons de donner à l'europe
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché sur
le premier biosimilaires de l'anticorps
monoclonal qui l'a qui est le
biosimilaire du remicade dont le chiffre
d'affaires national est relativement
important je pense que beaucoup d'entre
vous le connaissent 400 millions d'euros
et que dans l'année prochaine il y aura
un bio similaires à l'an biosimilaires
lui fait l'objet d'études cliniques
parce que c'est une molécule
biotechnologies sur avastin sur avastin
versus le lucentis je voudrais
simplement dire une chose premièrement
il n'y a aucun pays au monde qui
autorise la substitution de l'avastin au
lucentis
aucun pays au manque enfin atteindre
leurs responsables aucune agence ni
aucun gouvernement n'a pris cette
responsabilité
2 deuxièmement étant exposé excusez moi
je suis obligé de d'avoir fait l'heureux
le tour de tous mes collègues de toutes
les agences
on n'a pas interdit mais personne ne l'a
autorisée puisque c'est par nature ces
deux produits différents
deuxièmement nous avons des données de
pharmacovigilance il faut savoir ce
qu'on veut
faut que ça soit moins cher et moins
dangereux là on a parlé des génériques
ans et moins cher il faut que ça soit
équivalent et que ce soit pas plus
risqués dont les données
pharmacovigilance montrent qu' il ya
plus de toxicité lorsqu'on utilise la
vàd et l'avastin que le lucentis
bon elles sont rendues publiques à
l'échelle mondiale maintenant bon
certains peuvent accepter que c'est pas
grave si c'est plus toxiques parce que
c'est moins cher
je ne ferai pas de commentaire mais il
faut être transparent sur ce type de
sujet 3e dernière remarque là dessus
c'est que ce sont des produits
radicalement différent c'est comme si on
comparait l'aspirine et le paracétamol
les deux principes actifs sont
intéressants diminue le mal de tête ont
des effets inflammatoires mais une
molécule muté sur femmes c'est un petit
morceau n'a rien à voir et ne touchent
pas la même partie du principe actif qui
le verger mais pourquoi pas il arrive
que en prennent soin du paracétamol
le mal de tête par contre on ne les
considère pas comme équivalente il
substituables ce que c'est un autre
sujet voilà donc il ya une étude
clinique a été faite en france y ait une
méta-analyse donc ce n'est pas interdit
par contre les personnes qui le font
doivent assumer la responsabilité en cas
d'accident pour l'instant c'est ça la
situation en france et partout dans le
monde j'aurais rappelé que c'était très
popularisé aux etats unis puisque les
patients payent de leur poche et que
pour eux ça change beaucoup de choses
mais il n'est pas anormal effectivement
que la collectivité paye beaucoup
d'argent pour lui santis mais soyons
prudents sur les substitutions sur les
changements de traitement pour des
raisons purement économiques
s'il y a plus de toxicité en tous les
cas sont des produits différents et tous
de grande qualité vous aurait arbitré
prochainement les substitutions possible
sur les biosimilaires qui vont arriver
de façon très nombreuses
je suis obligé de vous dire que ce sont
deux produits différents et que la femme
a que le signe vigilance est différente
on a un collègue qui fête ses cochons ci
avec des ménages la réponse à la
question du sénateur agronome c'est ça
le roi oui monsieur le président je peux
répondre était étant chimiste de
formation
alors il faut bien comprendre que
lorsqu'on parle de celle du chlorure de
sodium c'est pas du sulfate de sodium je
suis d'accord le problème c'est qu'elle
est la partie active et si la partie
active et lyon c'est à dire le sodium
ce qui compte c'est sa diom c'est pas
l'agneau en contrepartie deuxièmement
lorsqu on absorbe par voie orale parle
je prends un produit qu'elle co j'ai par
exemple chlorhydrate de papa marine le
phosphate de peut pas gérer un béton ce
qui est actif c'est la papa verrines
quand je vais l'ingérer ce qui va passer
c'est la papa vers il est de toute façon
dans le sang il y aura plus de
chlorhydrate de chlorhydrate et s'est
diluée dans une masse énorme de chlorure
parce que le son est plein de chlorure
et il ya également des phosphates
donc si vous voulez lannion c'est-à-dire
l'espèce de l'autre partie de l'âme du
sel n'a aucune importance en la matière
par contre effectivement pour certains
c'est lille peut y avoir une importance
au niveau de la biodisponibilité
messahel et testé comme l'expliqué se
marrent anaky dans le fait que lorsqu'on
va tester par exemple un sulfate de 2,2
produit x et un autre un chlorhydrate de
ce produit x si on voit qu'il n'absorbe
pas de la même pub la même façon ce qui
est possible
voilà à ce moment là les produits ne
sont pas vus ou équivalent donc si on
montre que en mesurant la pape et
verrines par exemple pour prendre un
exemple qui est le principe actif dans
le sens exactement les mêmes paramètres
que le sel correspondant soit un sulfate
à face à tacle n'importe quoi tu te
moques une importance donc en
l'occurrence s'est testé effectivement
cet aspect là est testé dans la
bioéquivalence qui teste la totalité du
médicament quel qu'il soit plus ces
excipients qui peuvent et qui tend à
agir de façon considérable
son absorption de médicaments c'est
comme ça qu'on a montré les problèmes de
disponibilité lorsqu'il ya 4 50 ans on
avait changé les exceptions dans un
comprimé euro s'est aperçu que la
tendance était complètement différente
mais justement c'est pour ça
on fait des tests de bioéquivalence avec
la totalité des médicaments du
médicament excipients compris c'est tout
à fait fondamental ça je crois qu'il
faut pour préciser et si je peux
répondre à la question qui était posée
sur la prescription hospitalière de
sortie c'est un vrai problème je suis
d'accord avec vous moi je me bats
là-dessus à l'hôpital parce que nous on
se bat pour avoir les produits les moins
chers à l'hôpital et aux prescriptions
de sortie mais arriver les inspecteurs
la sécurité sociale qui vient de me dire
mais comment se fait-il nouveaux
prescripteurs en sortie prescrivent le
médicament le plus cher et je leur
réponds que le problème c'est que le
médicament le plus cher l'hôpital et pas
forcément le même qu'en ville donné que
les prix ne sont pas fixés de la même
façon et que deuxièmement je ne contrôle
pas en tant que pharmacien les
prescriptions de sortie on contrôle les
prescriptions hospitalières
ça veut dire que tous les moyens de
pressions possibles et imaginables sur
l'amas de la terne contient pour qu'ils
prescrivent le produit qu'ils veulent
plus cher en ville n'est pas contrôlable
c'est une mais je suis bien là que votre
avis je pense qu'il faudrait inciter
obligé à ce que la prescription de ville
tiennent de spital hier vers la ville
tiennent compte également des problèmes
de coûts bénéfices je suis totalement
d'accord
les serrures hors sujet merci monsieur
tilman merci monsieur le président je
vais essayer de répondre donc toutes les
questions sont intéressantes on veut pas
répondre à tout je voudrais d'abord
répondre à la question vous avez posé
des seuls je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit mon collègue astier il
ya quand même des choses qui sont un
petit peu gênante et en particulier dans
le rapport nous avons parlé du
clopidogrel parce que leur hydrate et le
benzène le sulfonate sont considérés
comme équivalents
alors c'est parfaitement légal puisque
dans l'art dans la réglementation
européenne les selles sont équivalents
là manifestement quand on va chercher
dans un bouquin de chimie ou deux ans
quand pharmacologie on s'aperçoit que
l'acide qui salit fille
le clopidogrel a1 une efficacité donc je
pense que
la réponse en général est bonne mais qu'
il ya un certain nombre de cas où on
pourrait quand même en discuter
je voudrais vous dire aussi que madame
vous avez parlé transparent je pense que
la transparence existe
le vrai problème je crois c'est la
pédagogie c'est d'expliquer et je crois
que vous avez mis le doigt sur le
problème de la formation des médecins
j'ai enseigné la pharmacologie blanc 35
ans je me suis battu pour avoir un
nombre minimum décent d'enseignement et
je crois que si vraiment il ya un
message que cette que vous pourriez
faire passer c'est à l'éducation
nationale c'est de revoir les poids
respectifs
parce que aujourd'hui le médicament
c'est devenu quelque chose de complexe
quand on a commencé nos études
il y avait une trentaine de médicaments
et tout se passait bien maintenant c'est
quelque chose c'est une discipline c'est
une science à part entière et je crois
qu'il faudrait le développer je voudrais
aussi vous dire que je voudrais aussi
vous dire que même avec une
bioéquivalence parfaite absolue sans
qu'on me sent bon le problème le
problème c'est celui du récepteur celui
qui le reçoit et on aura toujours une
variabilité parce que vous savez très
bien contre 2 saint divy du la même dose
de ne pas le même effet et vous savez
même que chez un même individu a des
temps différents la même dose
administrée par la même foi donne des
effets différents parcs on sait qu'on
peut parler plus loin là c'est la
variabilité et c'est pour ça que je
pense que s'ils voulaient le problème de
bioéquivalence mais j'ai pas tellement
voulu traiter parce que là mon avis est
un faux problème
il est résolu le problème c'est la
variabilité d'un individu et c'est pour
ça que je vous ai parlé donc de ces de
ses patients complètement déstabilisé au
parce que dure aussi parce que c'est ces
patients qui sont complètement
déstabilisé je suis persuadé qu'ils
réagissent différemment
je voudrais aussi vous dire la
substitution des génériques
il ya une chose qui est tout à fait
intéressante c'est que en toute rigueur
quand on place un générique par un autre
générique on devrait faire une étude de
bioéquivalence parce que le générique il
a été comparé au princeps
mais entre deux génériques
il peut y avoir aussi une variabilité et
là encore en toute rigueur entre 2
générées il faudrait faire une étude et
bong pas la faire c'est la raison pour
laquelle je bastia ce que je vous ai dit
quand on donne un générique on s'y tient
merci je pourrais sans excuse donc aux
intervenants qui sont déjà réglés pour
la table suivante table ronde suivante
mais on est quand même au coeur du
problème j'ai marqué j'ai vu que vous
manifestiez lorsqu'il y avait des
observations autour de vous oui donc les
deux premiers la parole j'ai deux-trois
réponse majeure a donné d'abord de notre
présidente caire qui a bien posé aussi
là la question de la transparence
ce que nous souhaitons tous la
transparence c'est dans les lois il
s'est peut-être la transparence est la
meilleure réponse à ce qui pourrait être
la désinformation
donc nous sommes engagés à rendre
transparent et accessible
déjà tous où toute la totalité des
dossiers des six cliniques pour
l'instant il ya un contentieux européen
qui portés par des firmes d'accord pour
empêcher l'accès des données
des essais cliniques ont autorisé là
mêmes dont je n'ai pas pour l'instant le
droit de le de viol et bien sûr la
législation mais nous espérons que ce
contentieux la france a pris position ce
n'est pas moi même mais enfin moi même
et nous avons pris position dans ce
contentieux pour que les données des
essais cliniques soient rendues
accessibles et public
et en ce qui concerne les génériques se
serait pas une grosse histoire puisque
seulement mon consiste à rendre publique
en ce qui nous concerne nous présentons
à les commissions et à des groupes et
sur votre saisine les données de
bioéquivalence des produits pour
lesquels j'engage responsabilité de
l'état lorsque je donne le là mêmes
elles n'ont rien de confidentiel ni de
secret voilà donc je crois que la
réponse de la transparence c'est
important
combien ne vient pas qu'il ya des partis
quand même qu'ils ont des intérêts
économiques et pour l'instant il ya un
contentieux qui bloque type bloquent
l'accès aux données fois l'arabe nous
faisons de notre mieux en france pour le
le rendre accessible et c'est pour ça
que nous publions régulièrement des
rapports avec le maximum de données pour
essayer de lutter contre une
désinformation qui nuit à propos des
données d'efficacité
ça a été un gros sujet voulons dire que
nous voulons pas comparer utiliser
l'argent public pour utiliser pour
comparer 60 générique entre eux
puisqu'ils sont identifiés pas toujours
la même opinion par contre la cnam très
façon originale et je crois qu'il faut
souligner ce travail qui a été fait a
voulu démontrer à l'ensemble des
médecins et des patients que lorsqu'on
fait une substitution bon voilà on a le
même effet thérapeutique et ça a été
fait avec avant la cie va statines nous
étions ensemble d'ailleurs pas pu
témoigner à une conférence de presse de
la cnam donc ça la même efficacité sur
la nation vit la même tolérance ça la
même inefficacité aussi ses bas ses
génériques ça marche mieux que le
princeps
mais quand le donne à 100 mille
personnes on a les mêmes effets que tu
en donnes le princeps à cent mille
personnes
donc c'est vrai que il ya quand même
beaucoup de résistance qu'on peut lever
et je crois qu'il faut saluer ce type
d'étude quand il ya un doute c'est pas
mal de faire une étude
maintenant il faut pas générer des
études qui ré un peu contre monsieur le
sénateur millions est parti donc je suis
désolé pour ceux nés pause et shopping
oui nous sommes dans la même région nous
connaissons bien
mais il sait aussi en tant que médecin
qu' il ya des histoires médical un peu
compliqué ou qu'il s'agisse d'un
générique ou d'un princeps d'une semaine
sur l'autre le même dicaments peut avoir
des effets secondaires
ça m'intéresse en tant que responsable
agence du médicament aussi d'avoir ce
type de signalement parce que
lorsqu'ils sont nombreux quel que soit
le produit
ça mérite d'être parce qu'après nous on
peut interroger la firme est aussi faire
des enquêtes sur les produits réellement
dont je voudrais conclure en interne en
110 ans n'hésitez pas à signaler dans
les système de pharmacovigilance
il ya eu l'année dernière quand même 38
min signalements qui ont été faits ce
qui est là aussi puisqu'on dit un
terrain lorsque la france n'est pas
terrible nous contribuons à 20 % des
signalements qui sont faits en europe et
nous représentons pas vraiment 20% de
c'est peut être mieux
donc continuons à signaler et qu'on
signale ça me permet d'analyser et de
rendre aussi des données transparentes
plutôt que de les garder pour soi où je
suis pas fort en pharmacovigilance
animal mais vous vous pouvez signaler
ces cas aussi c'est réglementairement
obligatoires
si messieurs les professeurs donc
devenir lecteur d'avoir bien voulu
répondre aux questions qui vous ont été
posées merci des éclairages qu'elle vous
avez bien voulu nous apporter
voilà pour la table ronde organisée par
la mission de contrôle et d'évaluation
de la sécurité sociale vous pourrez
évidemment revoir cette table ronde à
tout instant sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée à vous
sur notre chaîne